failure is essentially irrelevant unless
it is catastrophic
two pizza teams is something that we've
been preaching at amazon
almost from the very beginning and it's
a simple idea which is
we were so close we we you know i was
just too distracted i screwed
that up wanna be happy build a life not
just a business
hey it's evancar michael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you have michael jordan level genius at
something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the
seven best lessons from elon musk warren
buffett and other billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one maximize the useful
output with elon musk i think of the
these things is just
there's a certain amount of time and
within that time
you want the the best net
outcome so for
you know all the set of actions that you
can do there's
going to be uh and some of which will
fail some which will succeed
and you want the the net useful
output of your set of actions to be the
highest
um so
um i'm going to like use like a baseball
analogy like
you know baseball they don't let you
just sit there and wait for the perfect
pitch
until that you get a real easy one they
didn't give you
three shots and the third one they say
okay and they
get off the go back to the put somebody
else up there um
so these your three strikes on on the
baseball
um not you know not
only bad anymore so so
you're what you're really looking for is
like what's the batting average
you know how you're doing on
on score and just
there's going to be some amount of
failure
but you want your net output
net useful output to be maximized
failure is
essentially irrelevant unless it is
catastrophic
rule number two have integrity with
warren buffett all of you in this room
have the brains to do extremely well in
life
you've all got the energy to do
extremely well in life and then the
question is how do you apply it
if you've got a 200 horsepower motor you
get 200 horsepower out of it
you get your full potential or do you
get 100 horsepower or 50 horsepower
now there's two things that can hold you
back
in getting the full horsepower out of
your your engine whatever it may be all
of you have big enough engines
and one of those is a lack of education
but that probably isn't going to happen
to very many people in this room
if you did have a lack of education if
you didn't if you didn't have a chance
to get a decent education in life
it wouldn't make any difference what
that potential was because you'd never
unlock it
but the second most important thing and
equally as important
is in terms of the habits that you
develop in terms of what you do with
yourself
when we hire people we look for three
qualities
we look for integrity we look for
intelligence
and we look for energy but if they don't
have the first one integrity
the other two will kill you because if
you're hiring somebody without integrity
you really want to be dumb and lazy
don't you i mean you know
last thing in the world you want forms
to be smart energetic so
smart and energetic only goes with
integrity
but the nice thing about
you know you make your own decision on
that you can't change
your iq or how far you control football
or how high you can jump
or the color of your hair very easily
but you can
elect to have integrity that matches
anybody else's and if you match that
with intelligence which you have and
energy which you have
you will get an extraordinary result and
you'd be very foolish to sell me ten
percent of yourself for fifty thousand
on the other hand
if you don't match it with that your
potential will in a significant part
go unused rule number three build a
multitude of small
teams with jeff bezos two pizza teams is
something that we've been preaching at
amazon
almost from the very beginning and it's
a simple idea which is
no team should be so large that it
cannot be fed with just two pizzas
and uh and so obviously to do great
things you need big teams
but you need to subdivide them and the
reason that it's so helpful is because
there's a natural we humans grew up
around campfires and telling each other
stories
and you're sitting at tables tonight
that have about 10 people at each table
10 people maybe 12 people is the perfect
size
to have a natural human coordination
without a lot of structure and if you
want to have a
big group of 100 people or 500 people
organized you have to have a lot of
structure to make that work
and so if you can arrange to do big
things
with a multitude of small teams and that
takes a lot of effort to organize that
way
but if you can figure that out the
communication on those small teams will
be very natural and easy
also if you want to build more
confidence the sign says it can take up
to 254 days
of consecutive action to successfully
build
a habit so i've created a free program
for you where every day
for 254 days i will send you an unlisted
video to your email
absolutely free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description below
investing in yourself is the best thing
you can do anything that improves your
own talents like nobody can take it away
from me they can
run up huge deficits and the dollar can
become worth far
less you can have all kinds of things
happen key to success
is what you believe is true for yourself
those people who believe they're smart
they were headhunted by to the other
company they set up their own company
rule number four find your purpose with
oprah winfrey
the challenge of life i have found
is to build a resume that doesn't simply
tell a story
about what you want to be but it's a
story about who you want to be
it's a resume that doesn't just tell a
story about what you want to accomplish
but why a story that's not just a
collection of
titles and and positions but a story
that's really
about your purpose because when you
inevitably
stumble and find yourself
stuck in a hole that is the story
that will get you out what is your true
calling
what is your dharma what is your purpose
rule number five avoid distractions with
bill gates
there's no doubt that the anti-trust
lawsuit was bad for microsoft
and if we would have been more focused
on
creating the uh phone operating system
and so instead of using
android today you would be using windows
mobile
if it hadn't been for the honor trust
case uh microsoft would go oh we were so
close
we we you know i was just too distracted
i screwed that up
uh because of the distraction and you
know we were just three months too late
with the release that motorola would
have used on a phone
uh so yes uh it's a winner take all game
that
is for sure that you know now nobody
here has ever heard of windows mobile
uh but oh well and i wouldn't
uh well that's a few hundred billion
here or there
uh i wouldn't have retired
as soon and that one is less you know i
am disappointed that windows mobile
didn't succeed but in terms of
uh my own life you know even though it
was a very painful thing
because i got very personally involved
in the defense of the company
the fact that i retired earlier probably
net was good for me because i got
down the learning curve on the
foundation i got to partner with melinda
in the early days of the foundation
and you know i don't have a life where
i'm allowed to complain
because basically you know only 99 of
things have worked out very very well
lesson number six go for it with mark
cuban
my dad did upholstery on cars my mom um
did whatever odd jobs um but my dad was
always like if you want something you
have to earn it and
to his credit he never said no you can't
do that so whether it was selling
garbage bags baseball cards stamps
whatever it was
he never held me back and so i think
that was as important as anything
and you know sometimes being young and
trying things you're so naive and you
don't know any better
all you do is learn and if you fail it
doesn't matter and so
whether i was 9 10 12 16 21
the failures were irrelevant and you
know whether you're you know 9 12 16
21 22 24 you know i'm sleeping on the
couch
you know i have a car with a hole in the
floorboard you know i'm i'm living like
a bum and like a student
and so what did i have to lose and so i
think that influenced me as much as
anything so
you know my dad was like go for it you
know don't
why not what have you got to lose you
know you have to sleep on a different
couch
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is act with jackma
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
foreign
um
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and what is your plan of
action that you're going to execute this
week to make some immediate
momentum happen when you just get
motivated and watch a video
you have a 35 chance of following
through that's what the science says
but when you write down what time what
day what place you're actually going to
execute when you create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down in the comments
below
because i want to celebrate you
many times i've gone with what i thought
was fact and sometimes i thought were
pretty good hunches
and i didn't do so well but i'm very
fortunate that
more than 50 of the time i did do very
very well
and i'm finding out more recently in my
life the last couple years
that you try not to just think with your
brain but think with your heart
how do you feel about the situation how
do you feel about the people
no matter how kind they are and i've had
some really nice people
got in foreign countries and everything
else that were the nicest people in the
world
turned out to be total rip-offs but i
didn't know that
there were clues along the way so i say
to everybody
and i say to myself now feel the person
out or feel the situation with your
heart what is your instinct i think now
more in life
that i go off instinct plus facts you
obviously have to have some facts along
with it does it become easier the more
you do it
yep much easier when you're when you're
set to
well how do i feel about this shall we
say with data
stable data that i have how do i feel
about these facts and then and how i
feel about it
just my intuition how do i feel about it
from my heart and the more you think
about doing it that way the more it
happens
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free check out my
training right here below or if you want
seven more awesome lessons from
billionaires check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy
them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there